[Music]
[Applause]
we turn our attention to the Green Bay
Packers Pete Doherty covers the Packers
for the Green Bay Press Gazette
Pete how would you sum up what happened
last night
oh there's a couple ways of looking at
it I mean they look like a bad team for
a lot of the night but and I think Mike
takes up very much minority take but I
think Tennessee was a really really
really tough matchup for him the Packers
are a limited team they have to be able
to run the ball they just absolutely
have to and this was a team they were
not going to run the ball against you
force these guys to throw a weird thing
to say with Aaron Rodgers as your
quarterback right but you force them to
throw they've been bad all year when
they've had to throw a lot Riders
through 37 passes that right there tells
you it was a bad night for the Packers
he's got to be more in the 25 or under
range and they were not going to run the
ball against this team and the Packers
were on defense has been borderline
brutal a lot of times this year and
they're going against Derek Henry now
they had a decent game against them but
they totally had to sell out to stop the
run and Ryan Tannehill of all guys is
covering them up because they're he's
going against one-on-one coverage the
whole time so
I can't say that this was a stunning
loss they did look bad but they actually
have something going now with Christian
Watson that they didn't have even two
weeks ago it's just it's way too little
too late I mean it sure looks like that
what about Roger's thumb how serious is
it had some you know wobbly passes there
through a lot of passes for a guy if he
has something serious going on with that
thumb
uh your thoughts uh moving forward with
that injury he's had it for you know
it's got to be at least I got to go back
and look but probably five weeks or so
and he had it last week and he was
really really sharp last week so I can't
say that that's very likely the the
problem here it was just uh he had a bad
game accuracy wise he missed you know
three or four throws that you just you
gotta hit that he's made his living on
and um but like I said I thought this
was a really really tough matchup for
him too you know Tennessee's not that
good a team you know they're not one of
the top five teams in the league but I
don't know if you went through the
league and picked out the five teams the
Packers would least want to play they
might be on that list
at what point does Jordan love see some
air time
I don't think till they're out of
mathematically out of it
and then I think they have to give them
a look don't they I mean I was a couple
weeks ago before the Dallas game I was
thinking man that's going to be pretty
soon
um and then they played so well against
Dallas and gave themselves a lot some
life and that's why this was such a they
were I think they were stunned by
getting beat I think they thought they
had really found something turned the
corner yeah
um but obviously you know they're
they're I think they're improved from a
couple weeks ago but this was a really
tough matchup form and it's got to be
they got to see what love can do if they
if they're out of it they've got to see
what they have there because they've got
to make a decision on the fifth year
option and they can't have both him and
Rogers on the roster in 24 but they have
to make that decision next May
so you know that's that's a that's a
hard call I mean they either have to
work out with Rogers that he's gonna
retire or that they might have to deal
him where they'd have to deal love I
mean they have to do something there
well let me go back to what you were
saying about Rogers the likelihood he
comes back given what this season has
been we always hear athletes say or we
think they're going to say oh you can't
go out this way
well
can Aaron Rodgers go out this way
I
I find it really really hard to believe
that he'll retire there's probably
several reasons but one of them is he's
got a 59 million dollar guaranteed
contract as long as he doesn't retire
somebody's going to have to pay him that
59 mil I mean how many people would walk
are going to walk away from that I'm
thinking he also and he's not gonna if
Brady retires his offseason he's not
going to want to retire the same
off-season he does I mean they're both
going to go in the Hall of Fame on their
first shot you know I don't think he's
going to want to be the the number two
guy at that Hall of Fame ceremony do you
think Brady is going to retire oh I
don't I don't know
well maybe not maybe he'll be playing 30
years tonight I don't know it feels like
if you said who's going to retire first
I might say Aaron Rodgers yeah yeah a
couple weeks ago I was thinking Brady's
probably going to retire and all of a
sudden you know things change so fast in
this league I mean two weeks is like a
lifetime in this league sometimes
yeah I just wonder as it felt like
Devonte Adams left and then the Packers
lost their Identity or like now what do
we do and who's our go-to guy I can't I
can't pin it all in Devonte Adams who by
the way the Raiders aren't any good
either and he was supposed to go there
and help them
you know
they're they're receiving Corners young
they got new guys it's not just
overflowing with talent I don't think
it's as bad as everybody thinks it is
and Christian Watson certainly has
talent he's been hurt almost the whole
time this Romeo Dives I don't know if
you saw him at all he was their fourth
round pick There's real ability with
this guy I mean this guy can play now
he's out with a high ankle sprain he's
missed I think this was his third game
he's always going to miss at least one
more I would guess maybe a couple more
but actually going into next year if
they finish pretty decently they're
probably going to feel like they have
something going because those are two
pretty talented young receivers you seem
really calm Pete
I just woke up Dan I didn't get to bed
until three
and by the way with the background here
you look like you're in heaven you look
like
an angel I don't feel like it it's awful
cold outside right now uh it's great to
talk to you and uh thanks for joining us
we appreciate it all right thanks for
having me that's uh Pete Dougherty
covers the Packers for the Green Bay
Press-Gazette he kind of you know has
that you know that light backlit there
like St Peter's yeah next to him St Pete
no he is Saint Pete yeah St Pete there
welcome it's your time ah come in
welcome to the Pearly Gates well thank
you Pete he's very calm like all right
nothing don't worry about it so what you
know